political surprises the holy grail of
election campaigns but so often there's
more than meets the eye
pages and pages of censored blacked out
reports of secret US and UK talks about
breaking open our NHS at the height of
December's election campaign Jeremy
Corbyn brandished these documents from
the podium given the inside track on the
trade negotiations with the US and used
them to allege the Tories are selling
off the NHS today the government claimed
this leaked report was being promoted
online by Russians before Jeremy Corbyn
seized on it in other words an act of
interference in the 2019 election we
believe we know with reasonable
confidence that Russian actors were
involved in trying to interfere with the
2019 election principally through trying
to spread amplify online illegally
obtained leaked documents relating to
the UK u.s. free trade negotiations
there's a criminal investigation ongoing
the former Labour leader brushed off the
claim as a diversion while the Labour
Party today said we condemn any attempt
by Russia or any foreign power to
interfere in our country's democratic
processes labour stands ready to work
cross party to protect our nation's
security but even in labour
there have been worries about Russian
links you know the characters around
Jeremy Corbyn did you ever worry that
they weren't robust enough fending off
Russian advances I think historically on
the far left in British politics and
also incidentally on the far right
there's been a tendency to sort of
forgive Russia despite the fact that
it's a despotic regime journalists get
killed in their dozens with impunity
human rights are completely abused
without anybody saying boo and political
opponents are murdered just how
vulnerable is the British electoral
system well it's probably too early to
say on the basis of today's announcement
and despite the strike
headline conclusion that just isn't the
detail to come to a comprehensive
judgment now more details will probably
come out in the coming days when the
Intelligence and Security committees
report in to links between Russia and
British politicians is published but as
the diplomats in the building behind me
would tell you who benefits and how good
these attacks are well it's often very
murky people must learn how to defend
the UK political system better from the
Russians according to one of the authors
of next week's report it's important
people should know what Russia does but
I should gently point out that I think
people have been ignoring reality in the
past Russia we know interferes in
democratic processes not necessarily the
United Kingdom but it does the the the
evidence of this is absolutely clear-cut
so it's something which we in the United
Kingdom should be protecting ourselves
against insofar as we can I hope very
much when the report is published next
week people will have a greater sense of
that issue and of what may be possible
to do about it a landmark change that
Russia interfered in a British general
election for the first time last
December but we're only just starting to
understand what that looks like San
Coates Kyi's